hello everybody and welcome to the first
episode of my payt playay flipping
series for those of you just joining me
I had a freeo play series where I was
buying and selling in the grand exchange
and we went from zero GP to 5 mil and it
took about a month so now we are buying
the memberships right here and our new
goal is going to be a 100 Mil the rules
are going to be that I have to renew the
bond with the money I earn um so every
two weeks I'll be spending at least two
to 3 mil on renewing the membership uh
which is going to be kind of challenging
at first uh so that's the main Rule and
we have to get to 100 Mil uh no trading
money onto this account no accepting
donations anything like that so we're
just going to purely be using the profit
from the flips man it is so nice to have
the six off offer slots available uh
using three is real frustrating you
can't even get you can't really be
buying and selling the things at the
same time you have to buy them all and
sell them all I mean which is easier to
view but whatever um so we're going to
start off the first episode with some
random clue scroll items uh the Bandos
crosier uh which I have no idea why
you'd use it I guess you could use as a
Bandos item for God Wars or something um
but it pretty much seems useless um but
it has a pretty high margin on it now we
quickly decide against items like this
because we realizing this is going to
take a long time and we don't really
have now that there's a time crunch we
have to be going for kind of quicker
flips a little bit riskier um so we do
put the offer in for the crosier for
2500 each we're going to buy 30 of them
uh but I don't think we get anywhere
near that so we're going to try a couple
other items here and hopefully we'll
find some quicker moving
items uh next up we find the energy
potion uh which is very high moving uh
if it has a good margin on it I'm
definitely going to go for it yeah you
can see there I had about 50 or 60 GP on
it which is really good uh for how many
are traded every day uh so we'll go buy
uh quite a few of these for the low
price of about
522 and and yeah we're going to dump
most of our money in here so we'll do I
think 2,000 yeah and hopefully we can
find another item as
well next up I think we're going to go
with the mahogany logs uh which had a
pretty decent margin on them now this is
where you really want to check RS buddy
or some other website to make sure
you're not getting burn because the
price on these fluctuate quite a bit um
but it looked like I had a 20 30 GP
margin on them and the price was fairly
low compared to its historical values so
it should be fine uh but it is kind of
risky because you can even if it drops
like 10 GP you're losing 10 GP times
however many thousand you buy which can
really add up after a
while and lastly here I think we're just
going to buy one guilded plate skirt uh
I'm not going to not do freeo playay
items I'll try to Veer away from them at
the beginning but I'm really comfortable
with the free to-play items because I've
done them so many times where I'm just
getting used to the pay to playay items
which of course have many more
opportunities many more options but I
just don't know them as well so we'll
buy one gilded plate skirt for 280 and
yeah I'll check back when some stuff's
spot and sold
okay so everything is sold uh starting
with the crosier we made about 3,200 on
each one and we sold eight of them uh so
that's 28k there not too bad but it did
take a while uh the energy potions we
made the most on by far uh we sold them
for 44 GP profit and we stole 2,000 of
them uh so that's 90k in total and the
guilded plate skirt we just made an even
20K on so not too bad and the logs we're
kind of halfway through selling them uh
we're selling them for 13 GP profit and
we've sold about half of them so we made
about 920k on that or something and we
just have to dump the rest of them after
this so not too bad we made about 130k
and it honestly only took a couple hours
so if we do a couple more flips like
that we should be doing pretty well um
but yeah so we'll start by dumping the
mahogany logs in here they have dropped
down to about 250 uh but that's only
half of them so we should break even on
the flip at
least and uh next we're going to try a
couple more of these guilded plate
skirts cuz in the past they've worked
very well uh so we'll go for let's see
going to do five I think we'll do four
and uh yeah so we'll start with that no
we're doing we're doing three okay so
we're doing three
sorry okay so we are going to try the
combat potion it's kind of random but
you can see there had about 30 GP margin
on it uh we''ve been trying all these
random potions like one dose prayer
potions one do super combat potions um
but we found the combat potion which I
don't think I've ever used um so we'll
try this I I think we're going to buy,
1500 of these uh for a 30 GP margin is
pretty decent um we don't quite have
enough cash to do some of the most
popular items like uh prayer potions the
full dose like you need a lot of money
to successfully flip those so we're
going to try these random welfare
version of the same
potion okay and uh for the last item
here I think we're going to try the Rune
arrows you can kind of see me checking
the margin in the back uh Rune arrows
very quick moving tons of them traded
and 4 GP margins pretty decent uh for
the price point so yeah we're basically
just going to use the rest of our money
just to buy these uh it's not going to
be that many because we don't have much
cash left to work with but we just want
to try a couple different items just to
see which ones in the future might be
worth doing um so we're going to get
let's see here not quite that many we'll
get three or 4,000 probably in between
somewhere no we still can't afford it I
really bad at math sometimes uh so we'll
do yeah 3500 and yeah we'll see how well
that works and we'll check back
Okay so we've pretty much bought and
sold everything here um you can kind of
see the history we did pretty well on
most the items uh some of them we just
kind of made a pretty negligible amount
but uh we'll start with the plate skirts
since that actually was the best uh we
got 25k margin on each one we got three
so we got 75k in total for those uh the
Run arrows we actually got four GP on
each and we bought the
3500 uh so about 14k on those really
quick so I'm going to do those
definitely in the future
uh the combat potions we're getting N9
GP margin on and we've sold about 900 so
H we're getting like 8K from that and um
what's the last one logs yeah the logs
pretty much just broke even on so we're
just gonna forget that
happened um so yeah not too bad we
probably made 100K on that flip
transaction um so yeah we'll try to pick
some better items going forward um the
plate skirt's nice it is a free toplay
item though so we'll try to get some
better members items really thought it
was going to a lot easier but it's going
to take a while before I find some good
members items that are consistently good
profit so we're just going to start off
by checking what the combat potion's at
now it's at
472 um so actually that's not too bad
it's just taking forever to sell and see
we're selling for 473 before so yeah we
will just dump those so we'll still make
another 9k or something from that which
is pretty bad uh but what are you going
to
do okay so we are going to do a couple
more of the guilded plate skirts just
because they've been such good money uh
we're really trying not to invest all
our money in this but it's a tough
decision between actually consistently
getting some money to start with and
discovering new items that will most
likely be better in the future uh but
it's hard to say because I need to make
at least 200k a day I mean I have a bit
of wiggle room because I started with
more money but I don't really want to be
losing money here because that will just
be going backwards um so I mean we were
a couple couple days in and we're doing
pretty good it's just we need to be
doing faster flips and to do faster
flips we need more money um so we're
actually going to buy four of these I
think and for 290k so hopefully get 20
or 30k on
those uh next up we're going to try the
gothics page you may see that briefly I
sold them for 5,000 each and bought them
for 18K so that's a really good margin
on it now I'm not going to say see if
it's going to stay there that long um
but might as well give it a try so we'll
try to buy 20 of these for 6K each and
hopefully get like 12K margin on each
one that seems doable um but hopefully
it won't rise up before I bought in a
decent amount of these at least uh yeah
so we'll do 50 and leave it at that and
lastly I think we're going to try the
pineapple seed had a decent margin on it
now the price is a little bit higher
than it's usually been so this might not
be a great idea but we're going to give
it a try we're not going to put too much
money in here yeah it's not so bad and
um yeah so it seemed like you can see
that had a 800 GP margin on it which is
really good for how much it costs and
there's a decent amount of them traded
every day so we'll give this item a try
again we're just really trying to do a
bit of feelers in different types of
items different prices just to see what
is going to be consistently good going
forward because we'll need more than
just a couple items to be able to uh
afford a bond every couple weeks um so
yeah we'll go and buy these for like
4500 and we'll just use the rest of our
cash and hopefully it will work
out okay so everything has sold
uh to start off here the um the combat
potions we just basically made nothing
on so we'll just ignore that um the
plate skirts we made 26k on each again
which is really good I'm making this
about 104k in total we'll just get our
history open here so we can have a look
see um so let see uh yeah the plate
skirts you can see there we got 26k
margin on each you can see the
difference there it's about 100K plus
the goth Gothic Pages we only managed to
get four of but we got a 12K margin each
one which is pretty decent you can kind
of see there we got them for 6,000 sold
for 18,000 which is good and the
pineapples we're in the process of
selling we're getting a 777 GP margin on
each one and we've sold couple of them
so far maybe like 15 or something making
this about 10K so whatever it's not so
bad uh we'll just start off by dumping
the pineapples again uh hopefully the
margin hasn't changed too much uh mind
you we got for 4500 and it's screwed so
yeah we will dump that at probably uh
even break even on that uh which is fine
so in total we made about
50k which is still pretty good the bulk
of that still coming from the plate
skirts
though and on that note we will buy some
more of the plate skirts um because
we're just making pretty good money on
them we'll buy another couple of those
let's see we'll go with five this time
buying them for 285 this time hopefully
getting 20 or 30k on those again that
would be
awesome up next here think we're going
to try the one do prayer potion you can
see there had actually a 500 GP margin
on it and I just checked ours buddy
there's a couple thousand of these
traded every day so it's pretty decent
for the margin that has on it uh so
we'll buy with the majority of our money
we'll buy these prayer potions so we're
going to get them for around 2950 I
think yeah no exactly 2950 and we'll buy
a couple hundred and uh we're not going
to get too many for one we don't have
enough money and um we're not quite sure
how quickly moving they're going to be
so we'll buy 300 and we'll find one last
item so we're getting a little bit tired
here so we couldn't really find an item
so we're just going to kind of put a bit
of a shot in the dark while we go to bed
so we'll try to buy these gothics Pages
four uh for like 7K each and it's
totally random we'll hopefully get a
couple but who knows so we'll check back
when I wake
up okay so it's the morning now and um
we locked out on some items um and some
not so plate skirts we did not manage
buy any of so that was useless the um
pineapple seeds we were just breaking
even on remember um so that was pretty
much nothing now the prayer potion one
dose went really well we got a 450
margin on each one and we sold 300 you
see there it's about 135k we made on
those that's really good we're going to
have to try that again and the gothics
page we just got one of them but we
still got a 13k margin on that so not so
bad really uh but the prayer potions
really decent not sure how long they
took cuz I left it in overnight but
obviously not too long so I think think
we're going to try them again because
they're very successful um so we'll
check the margin again we buying them
for
3500 uh selling them for 20 yeah so
that's really good so that's 550 GP on
each one and they do buy pretty quick so
we'll go ahead and buy some more of
those for around the 2950 Mark again and
uh 2970 this time and we'll go buy I
think we're going to do 4500 this time
just because they were very successful
and for the second item here I think
we're going to try the Mystic boots uh
which you can see there has about
a 750 or 700 GP margin each one um which
is pretty decent they are sold pretty
frequently because they're used for Ping
they're used they're just kind of the
mid tier boots um so there's a lot of
them traded every day so we'll buy them
for 6450 and we'll get 100 of
those next up I think we're going to try
the Rune arrows again they had a pretty
decent margin on them again once again
we don't have much money left over but
uh yeah whatever we'll try these again
I think I had a 4gp margin on them again
and we'll go
by why are we're doing the 100
multiplier oh my God it's taking a
while okay we're going to buy the most
the majority of our money with the rest
of these run arrows and we'll leave a
little bit just for a slower item and
for the last item here I think we'll try
a Bandos page I see we bought it for 10K
and uh we'll just pop in for
one and it sold for 6.8 so that's not so
bad um we'll give give it a try we only
have 150k left anyway and I'm getting a
little tired of trying to find items uh
so yeah we'll plop in for
6,900 and we'll buy 10 or 20 of these go
for 20 all right we'll check back in a
couple
hours okay so we have sold everything
and I think we're going to call this the
end of the episode um so to end it all
off we uh managed to buy 129 of the
prayer potions at a 550 GP margin each
which is really good uh we got about 70k
from those we didn't manage to buy
nearly as many who wanted but uh still
got a good amount of money from those
you can kind of see it right there the
difference uh we bought for 380k and
still for
451 uh the Mystic boots went really well
as well we got all 100 of them and we
got about a 9910 GP margin on each so we
got about 91k from that run arrows were
super quick and easy we got three GP on
each one and we got 4,500 of them so
that's about 13k there Bandos Pages were
just not flya so we have uh now we're
making onek on each of those so we have
to sell about eight more of those so in
total this episode we got about 700k
because after we sell those band those
pages we'll be at about 3 mil and we
started the day well not the day we
started the week kind of at 2.3 mil so
we got 700k and it's been about three
days we have 10 days left in our
membership now uh 10 in a bit so it's
really close I'm basically breaking even
now so hopefully once we get to a bit of
higher cash stack we can start earning a
bit more cuz right now it's really close
I kind of getting some Major's mask
Vibes like this is day number three and
I have to like reset it um but hopefully
going forward this will go a little bit
better so I hope you guys enjoyed uh if
you did just hit that subscribe button
and I'll see you guys uh next episode
[Music]